Jake:唉
Jake: Hey
Jake:2038
Jake: 2038
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Jake:怎么一点用都没有呢
Jake: Why is it completely useless?
Shure: 不知道啊
Shure: No idea
Jake:是没有一点用吗
Jake: It's totally useless?
Jake:有用吗修硕
Jake: Is it useful, Shure?
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:他醒着的对吧
Jake: He's awake, right?
Nicous: 给别人弹琴行不行
Nicous: Can he play the piano for others?
Nicous: 我们又没事
Nicous: We don't have anything to do
Jake:哈哈哈加油加油加油
Jake: Hahaha, come on, come on, come on
Shure: 雨轩雨轩
Shure: Yuxuan, Yuxuan
Jake:打游戏了
Jake: Playing games
Jake:我估计插耳机
Jake: I guess he's using earphones
Nicous: ok ok过一会要过来集合ok
Nicous: Okay, okay, we need to gather in a bit, okay
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:把菜质量这么好了
Jake: The food quality is so good
Jake:你醒了
Jake: You're awake
Jake:敲不醒你
Jake: Can't wake you up
Jake:敲不醒
Jake: Can't wake up
Jake:他露西敲不醒
Jake: Lucia, can't wake him up
Jake:他醒了以前都是他醒不了
Jake: He woke up, usually he can't wake up
Jake:每人都有醒不了的时刻
Jake: Everyone has moments they can't wake up
Jake:人均醒不了
Jake: Everyone can't wake up
Katrina: 你刚洗了吗
Katrina: Did you just wash?
Shure: 有一点
Shure: A little
Jake:有一点有点粉
Jake: A little powdery
Shure: 有点紫
Shure: A bit purple
Katrina: 没啥子
Katrina: It's nothing
Jake:有一种这个粉色的感觉
Jake: There's this kind of pink feeling
Katrina: 哈哈哈你还是就是
Katrina: Hahaha, you still are just
Katrina: 这这这是确实粉紫色的
Katrina: This, this, it's really pinkish purple
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah
Jake:感觉到了
Jake: I can feel it
Shure: 帮忙叫一下
Shure: Help call out
Jake:来两位帮忙帮个忙吧
Jake: Hey, you two, help out
Shure: 你要不私闯进去
Shure: Why don't you just barge in
Jake:弹了给个背景音
Jake: Play it and give it some background music.
Jake:是灯啊还亮
Jake: The lights are still on.
Katrina: 不在
Katrina: Not here.
Jake:不在
Jake: Not here.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:在外边吗难道
Jake: Are they outside?
Jake:哎呀哎呀
Jake: Oh dear, oh dear.
Katrina: 哎呀哎呀
Katrina: Oh dear, oh dear.
Katrina: 瞎吧
Katrina: Blind?
Shure: 我寻思得睡多死啊
Shure: I was thinking, how deep must they be sleeping?
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake:在还是不在啊
Jake: Are they here or not?
Katrina: 不在啊
Katrina: Not here.
Jake:不不在啊
Jake: Not, not here?
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Jake:问问
Jake: Ask around.
Katrina: 偶买噶增加一点悬疑的情节唉
Katrina: Oh my God, add some suspense to the plot.
Jake:这剧本挺好啊
Jake: This script is pretty good.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake:是在这吗
Jake: Are they here?
Jake:是在厕所吗
Jake: Are they in the bathroom?
Jake:会吗
Jake: Could they be?
Katrina: 厕所他也会回答我们呀
Katrina: They'd answer us from the bathroom too.
Jake:那应该得听见是吧
Jake: We should be able to hear them, right?
Katrina: 对啊
Katrina: Yeah.
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Hehe.
Jake:头疼
Jake: Headache.
Jake:哎哈喽哈喽
Jake: Hey, hello, hello.
Jake:你在哪呢
Jake: Where are you?
Lucia:啊我在外面就是我在
Lucia: Ah, I'm outside, I mean I'm at...
Lucia:这块这个卫生所这
Lucia: this health clinic here.
Lucia:因为今天下午那个小狗
Lucia: Because this afternoon, the puppy...
Lucia:它把我手稍微划了一下吗
Lucia: it scratched my hand a bit.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:我家人不太放心让我打个疫苗
Lucia: My family wasn't too sure, so they wanted me to get a vaccine.
Jake:哦    这么回事
Jake: Oh, that's why.
Lucia:而而且对我看了一下
Lucia: And, and also, I checked...
Lucia:那个地方它一直有点红
Lucia: the area is still a bit red.
Lucia:然后我想着就要不然就来打一下吧
Lucia: So, I thought, why not come and get it done.
Jake:唉 好好
Jake: Oh, okay, sure.
Jake:那你你在哪啊
Jake: Where are you now?
Lucia:我在就是这附近有个卫生所
Lucia: I'm at a clinic nearby.
Lucia:这叫什么你稍等一下哈
Lucia: What's the name... give me a second.
Jake:你要发个定位过来吧
Jake: Why don't you send your location?
Jake:然后我们大概有个数
Jake: So we have a rough idea.
Jake:对  因kiss别丢了
Jake: Yeah, so we don't lose you.
Lucia:叫叫叫张家湾
Lucia: It's called Zhangjiawan.
Lucia:张家湾卫生院
Lucia: Zhangjiawan Clinic.
Jake:请你发个定位过来好吧
Jake: Please send the location, okay?
Jake:好好好行 大概什么时候回来
Jake: Okay, sure. When will you be back roughly?
Lucia:呃 不知道说等一会
Lucia: Uh, not sure, maybe in a bit.
Jake:稍等一会就是你是打了还是还没打
Jake: So, did you get it done or are you still waiting?
Jake:还是在排队还是啥
Jake: Or are you still in line or what?
Lucia:刚跟那个大夫咨询完
Lucia: Just finished consulting the doctor.
Lucia:然后就是我觉得正好还是打一个
Lucia: And I think it's better to get it done now.
Jake:哦哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, okay.
Jake:好嘞好嘞
Jake: Got it, got it.
Jake:行行那你别着急
Jake: Alright, don't rush.
Jake:行就就这样吧
Jake: Okay, let's leave it at that.
Lucia:好嘞拜拜
Lucia: Alright, bye-bye.
Jake:好嘞拜拜
Jake: Okay, bye-bye.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 不见了吗露亚
Katrina: Where's Lucia?
Jake:他去卫生所了
Jake: She went to the clinic.
Katrina: 怎么了不舒服啊
Katrina: Is she not feeling well?
Jake:他呃去玩狗的时候被狗抓了一下
Jake: She got scratched by a dog while playing and she's worried.
Jake:他不放心
Jake: So she's getting vaccinated.
Jake:打疫苗去了
Jake: Uh-huh.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:白敲啦
Jake: What a waste.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Alice:去哪打了呀
Alice: Where did she go for it?
Jake:就附近的一个卫生所
Jake: Just a nearby clinic.
Jake:怎么了玩的这个
Jake: What's up with this?
Katrina: 你要等他回吗
Katrina: Are you waiting for her to come back?
Jake:不用了
Jake: No need.
Katrina: 直接我们讨论
Katrina: Let's discuss directly.
Shure: 加了我食指中间
Shure: Added between my index finger.
Jake:对直接讨论
Jake: Yeah, let's discuss it directly.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:唉还有一个人没选会没出来了
Jake: Oh, there's still one person who hasn't chosen yet.
Katrina: 破门而入
Katrina: Break in.
Shure: Natasha
Shure: Natasha.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Shure: 乌日啦mother rush
Shure: Urijah, mother rush.
Shure: i need you
Shure: I need you.
Katrina: 感觉骂的很脏
Katrina: That sounds really dirty.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Shure: ralish
Shure: Relish.
Shure: 好的傻
Shure: Okay, silly.
Jake:我靠
Jake: Oh crap.
Jake:抽象确实抽象
Jake: Abstract, truly abstract.
Katrina: 我那个香薰还蛮香的
Katrina: My fragrance is pretty nice.
Shure: 我让他给我占个位置
Shure: I asked him to save me a spot.
Shure: 哎我是不是把iPad拿外面了
Shure: Oh, did I leave my iPad outside?
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
Shure: 拿回来了吗
Shure: Did you bring it back?
Jake:嚯短袖短裤
Jake: Wow, short sleeves and shorts.
Jake:唉  门开了
Jake: Oh, the door is open.
Jake:但是
Jake: But...
Shure: 但是什么
Shure: But what?
Jake:人呢
Jake: Where is everyone?
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Katrina: 斯班当时他们乐队有唱
Katrina: At that time, their band sang.
Jake:我先把这个关了
Jake: Let me turn this off first.
Jake:然后再给你开
Jake: Then I'll turn it back on for you.
Jake:他要重启一下比较好
Jake: It’s better to restart it.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:没有 让 我现在去揉
Jake: No, let me rub it now.
Jake:这个我先放你这里边
Jake: Let me put this here first.
Jake:然后你暂时先不用充电
Jake: You don’t need to charge it for now.
Katrina: 唉 噔噔噔噔噔噔噔
Katrina: Oh, dum dum dum dum dum.
Jake:然后一会充电在拿
Jake: Then charge it later.
Tasha:今天是在这偷的是吧
Tasha: Are we stealing here today?
Jake:对外边冷了
Jake: Yeah, it's cold outside.
Shure: 唱不下去太高了
Shure: Can't continue singing, too high.
Shure: 我们可以唱一点简单
Shure: We can sing something simple.
Shure: 你们有听过朴树的new boy吗
Shure: Have you guys heard of Pu Shu's "New Boy"?
Shure: 就是这一首
Shure: It's this song.
Jake:这朴树的
Jake: This is Pu Shu's.
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yeah.
Jake:这么回事
Jake: What's the deal with it?
Shure: 这哥岁数比咱都大
Shure: This guy is older than all of us.
Shure: 咦什么人
Shure: Eh, who's that?
Jake:你看见过
Jake: Have you seen it?
Katrina: 你明天早上就
Katrina: Tomorrow morning, you...
Katrina: 把我们叫醒然后就坐这弹然后我们就醒了
Katrina: Wake us up, play it here, and we'll be up.
Shure: 让我暖洋洋
Shure: Make me feel cozy.
Katrina: 一下可以叫醒三个
Katrina: It can wake up three at once.
Shure: 好
Shure: Alright.
Shure: 我直接开始国际歌起来
Shure: I'll start with the "Internationale".
Jake:国际歌用吉他合适合不合适
Jake: Is it appropriate to play the "Internationale" on a guitar?
Shure: 合适
Shure: Yes, it is.
Jake:合适
Jake: It is.
修硕能:能唱我们我们
Shure: Can we sing it though, can we?
Shure: 主要是看我们能不能唱
Shure: It depends if we can sing it.
Jake:能唱能唱
Jake: We can sing it.
Jake:国际歌怎么了
Jake: What's wrong with the "Internationale"?
Jake:你又没唱
Jake: You haven't sung it.
Jake:算了呵
Jake: Forget it, haha.
Shure: 呵我知道你想说什么
Shure: Haha, I know what you want to say.
Shure: 杨老板你很危险
Shure: Jake, you're very dangerous.
Jake:你不知道
Jake: You don't know.
Shure: 我真不知道吗
Shure: Do I really not know?
Jake:你知道
Jake: You know.
Shure: 我该不该知道呢
Shure: Should I know?
Jake:我不知道你知不知道
Jake: I don't know if you know.
Katrina: 唱
Katrina: Sing.
Shure: 唱什么国际歌吗
Shure: Sing the "Internationale"?
Jake:来
Jake: Come on.
Shure: 我找一张谱子
Shure: I'll find the sheet music.
Katrina: 所以我们在等待什么
Katrina: So what are we waiting for?
Shure: 我在等待
Shure: I'm waiting.
Jake:唉
Jake: Hey.
Jake:哈哈对啊
Jake: Haha, yeah.
Jake:你在干哈
Jake: What are you doing?
Shure: 起来  哎呀
Shure: Get up. Oh man.
Jake:你在里边吗
Jake: Are you in there?
Jake:他不在里面
Jake: He's not inside.
Jake:他哪去了
Jake: Where did he go?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 你以后跟我说
Katrina: Tell me next time.
Katrina: 要带一个那个GPS模块了
Katrina: We need to bring a GPS module.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Jake:人均
Jake: Per person.
Katrina: 哈哈哈人均丢失一次
Katrina: Hahaha, each person gets lost once.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:我刚刚想说一个人的名字
Jake: I was about to mention someone's name.
Jake:但是不敢说
Jake: But I didn't dare.
Jake:算了
Jake: Never mind.
Jake:我来吧
Jake: I'll do it.
Jake:手套呢我看到了
Jake: I saw the gloves.
Jake:哎呀不要
Jake: Oh no, don't.
Jake:啊哦哎呦我去
Jake: Ah, oh, ouch!
Jake:我带反了是吧
Jake: Did I wear it backwards?
Jake:我靠好难带啊
Jake: Damn, it's so hard to put on.
Jake:我要不弄个新手套
Jake: Should I get a new glove?
Tasha:没有新手套了
Tasha: There are no new gloves.
Jake:那我就这么揉吧
Jake: Then I'll just knead it like this.
Jake:我要揉成什么样
Jake: What should I knead it into?
Jake:what what would you
Jake: What, what would you...
Jake:找谢彬竹去
Jake: Go find Xie Binzhu.
Jake:哎谢彬竹
Jake: Hey, Xie Binzhu.
Jake:给你个任务
Jake: I have a task for you.
Jake:那个露西在是卫生所
Jake: Lucia is at the clinic.
Jake:对 yinkiss怕有什么问题
Jake: Yeah, yinkiss might have some issues.
Jake:我们规避风险
Jake: We need to avoid risks.
Jake:哈哈哈哈你去找找她
Jake: Hahaha, go find her.
Jake:你你你你加她你或者你把手机
Jake: You, you, you add her, or you take your phone.
Jake:你加她微信吧然后对
Jake: Add her on WeChat, yeah.
Jake:嗯 大晚上这个村里自已走
Jake: Hmm, it's really creepy to walk alone in the village at night.
Jake:确实怪寒碜的
Jake: Be careful.
Jake:你也注意安全
Jake: Stay safe.
Jake:不不不不不
Jake: No, no, no, no, no.
Jake:我要干嘛
Jake: What am I doing?
Jake:把他们叫下来吧
Jake: Call them down.
Jake:唉你开灯的吗
Jake: Hey, did you turn on the lights?
Tasha:哎
Tasha: Hey.
Jake:我靠呵呵呵刚睡醒
Jake: Oh my gosh, I just woke up.
Tasha:把他们叫下来干啥
Tasha: Why are you calling them down?
Jake:因为他们我们要讨论一下这个
Jake: Because we need to discuss this with them.
Tasha:做好之后带上去吧
Tasha: Let's finish it and take it up to them.
Jake:他们他们先讨论是吧
Jake: They should discuss it first, right?
Jake:也行
Jake: Okay, that works too.
Tasha:您不在行
Tasha: You aren't capable.
Tasha:没有人否认的样子
Tasha: No one is denying it.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:那那不是我
Jake: That's not me.
Jake:我得告诉他们
Jake: I need to tell them.
Jake:得讨论
Jake: We need to discuss it.
Tasha:那你上去要告他们
Tasha: Then go up and tell them.
Jake:好的行
Jake: Alright, got it.
Jake:我在揉面
Jake: I'm kneading dough.
Katrina: 你在揉面
Katrina: You're kneading dough.
Jake:对你们把曲子定了吧
Jake: Yes, you guys decide on the song.
Jake:你们仨把曲子定了吧
Jake: The three of you decide on the song.
Katrina: 所以说我把开会流程变成我们三个了
Katrina: So, I changed the meeting process to just the three of us.
Jake:我把这
Jake: I'll...
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Shure: 然后就是把曲子定一下就好
Shure: So, just decide on the song.
Jake:曲子定一下
Jake: Decide on the song.
Katrina: 谁会唱歌
Katrina: Who can sing?
Jake:明天明天安排
Jake: We'll arrange it for tomorrow.
Katrina: 柯欣你唱吗
Katrina: Ke Xin, can you sing?
Jake:明明天明天探探走一遍明
Jake: We'll go over it tomorrow.
Katrina: 咱搞一个合唱呗就不跳舞了
Katrina: Let's do a chorus, no dancing.
Alice:我
Alice: I can.
Jake:对明天他们俩和
Jake: Yes, they will do it tomorrow.
Jake:就是其实明天就是彩排
Jake: Actually, tomorrow is just a rehearsal.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Jake:和收视方面
Jake: And for the ratings.
Katrina: 唱呗不然就我们两个
Katrina: Let's sing, otherwise, it's just the two of us.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Shure: 我们俩唱
Shure: We will sing.
Katrina: 多尴尬啊
Katrina: How awkward is that?
Shure: 唱素颜 哈哈哈
Shure: Sing "No Makeup" haha
Katrina: 我们两个直接唱破音
Katrina: We'll both go off key
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:唱对
Jake: Sing it right
Jake:可以可以
Jake: Alright, alright
Katrina: 哎素颜很适合
Katrina: Yeah, "No Makeup" fits well
Katrina: 吉他那个耶
Katrina: The guitar part, right?
Shure: 好像是
Shure: Seems like it
Jake:那你们聊聊
Jake: You guys chat
Jake:然后彩排也聊一聊
Jake: And discuss during the rehearsal too
Katrina: 我感觉唱歌比唱歌可以唱个俩
Katrina: I feel like we could sing this one twice
Jake:我我们揉完应该就上来了
Jake: Once we finish, we should go on stage
Jake:也揉个20分钟吧
Jake: Should be about 20 minutes